we begin with breaking news three people
have been killed and several others
wounded in a shooting in the Dutch city
of Utrecht Dutch police say they are
searching for a 37 year old Turkish born
man in connection with the incident they
have named the suspect as a gov'ment
Tannis and released this image and
people are being warned not to approach
him but to contact authorities emergency
services are at the tram station in
Utrecht city centre where the shooting
was first reported the city's mayor says
a terror motive is the most plausible
explanation rick's zynga is a crime
reporter at our TV attract he joins us
on the line from the city welcome to DW
Rick's let's start with the the suspect
this gökmen at Tanis so what can you
tell us about him a good day to you too
well we found out that document Janus is
very well known to the police it was
previously convicted at least five or
six times for burglary bicycle thefts
threatening a police officer and two
weeks ago he was in court in a rape case
well apparently he was in jail but
apparently in a waiting surface case he
has been freed and an interesting thing
in 2013 he was also convicted for an
incident with with a gun he apparently
shot at apartment at an apartment
building not far from where the shooting
today took place and it was converse
convicted for that and for owning a
weapon and some other stuff back then in
2013 already what's being said about a
motive well about a motive I think it's
it's more and more probable that it has
something to do with in the relational
it could have been something like a
blood revenge it doesn't look like a man
who would put committed a terror attack
in the neighborhood people say that he's
crazy
that he's not a stable person so what
well on one side you could say well
maybe he is inspired by something like
what happens in Christchurch New Zealand
on the other hand it could be something
completely different people are saying
that it was his sister-in-law who was
one of the victims oh that's not
confirmed but if it is so I think we
have to rule out that it was really a
terror attack but meanwhile authorities
are still keeping up the highest level
of security security walk us through the
sequence of events as we know because
the picture is quite unclear at the
moment as to how many shootings there
there there were and and what happened
so to the best of your knowledge what
was the sequence of events well at a
quarter to 11 we got the message that
that would have been a shooting in or
near a tram in in the city of your
church in canalla
along after that we got another message
that a woman had been shot by at least
four men and then news started popping
up of incidents all around town police
raided homes all around town not only in
the area where the shooting took place
so well so sort of panic here took took
hold of people schools were closed and
that of course is something that when
you put up the security level is
automatically done you check just got
the most important train station in the
Netherlands so the trains the train
station was was shut down well there was
so much not known about what was going
on
and with the terror attack in New
Zealand in the back of our heads and a
couple of months ago a terrorist cell a
real one was discovered in in Holland
and what I think an explanation for this
is this big thing it it became good
talking to
Rick's thank you so much for joining us
sir Rick's a singer in Utrecht in the
Netherlands so this of course is
happening in the wider context of
attacks around the world DW Sahana
cleaver is here to just sort of fill us
in so what are the strong suspicions
then is that this was a terror attack
yes but it there are also some
significant suggestions suggest that
this might have been a personal thing
that was going on and really it's the
response that matters it's this you know
all these images of armed security
people on the streets of you know we saw
recently I think even like one of those
robots that they send in to see whether
there's a bomb knocking around it's this
response this panic this fear this sense
of uncertainty and that is we can see
there the effect of terrorism globally
taking effect that's what people want to
achieve and whether the terrorists are
Islamist extremists or far-right
fascists this is exactly what they want
to achieve and they're doing that
there's no other way that the security
services in any country could possibly
react but this is really this is the
fruit this is the the harvest of a
terror attacks around the world that's
what we're seeing and of course it's a
responsibility on media to behave in a
certain way that some people might even
call censorship people would I mean some
people could call that censorship I mean
with with the the New Zealand killing
there was plenty of video I mean the guy
was live-streaming his attack as he as
he carried it out that was in all on an
awful lot of social media which was then
repeatedly taken down I think more than
a million times most responsible
journalism houses ourselves included
aside to the instantly not to broadcast
any of that but there are there are
signals that people give that when
the main suspect in Christchurch was in
front of the court yesterday he was
making a sign with his hands which many
people were saying there's a far-right
extremist sign those are things that the
media has to decide whether to broadcast
or not we decided the most most
responsible media decided not even to
show his face because you don't want to
create another anders breivik the guy
who showed up all those people in in
Norway you don't want to create another
hero you know another Muhammad Atta does
doesn't even matter which side of the
fence you're on you don't want to create
these heroes and so the shooting we're
hearing about now in attract we're
talking about that the Netherlands which
like New Zealand a society often praised
as being a spring world wide open right
and you know Holland is is almost
similar to New Zealand I mean it's a
nice happy small little open society but
that comes at a cost you know Holland is
the kind of society where you could have
a film a collector of Van Gogh make a
film criticizing the violence that takes
place against women within the context
of Islam but Hollanders also the place
where he was then in 2004 murdered on
the street by Islamist extremists
because of the film he made Holland is
the place where you can say in many ways
you've had very successful integration
of refugees of migrants from all over
the world but it's also the home of
karakurt villas who is massively
anti-muslim and and inspired this huge
pegida movement which is spread around
Europe and in fact in January there was
a pegida demonstration and you trashed
in front of a mosque I mean that you've
got this two sides of things which
really therein is this huge conflict
that you can see around the world now
all right so yeah given that we don't
know whether this was a personal or or a
wider terror attack then the response is
something we have to just get used to
the response is the new normal that's
where we've arrived at and I don't see
personally really how we can get away
from that when some guy you know if it's
a personal thing that happened today if
he decides to shoot his girlfriend or
something for disrespecting him or for
leaving him or something
that nowadays was triggers this huge
response because people are worried it's
a terrorism attack well how to clever
thank you so much